all right what what are your names my
name is Scotty C Wayne CAD Scotty Wayne
on the left Scotty on the right yeah and
uh you guys grew up here in uh here in O
West West Virginia in odd yeah we we're
sitting in Larry's truck yeah back in
Larry's truck and tell story from when
we was a kid I mean but how'd you grow
up we grew up our parents we we a l i
mean we I mean we was kind of poor
people everybody's poor here yeah I mean
it's it's it's normal I mean I think
this is probably one of the poorest
parts of the country yeah yeah and um we
U we always when we was kids we we
scared of the Whitakers you know cuz our
grandpa lived down here and um and when
we got older we realized they nor normal
people like like us I mean that when we
used to come down here to see our
grandpa you know we were just kids at
the time
and we would have to walk down through
here by here and we never wanted to come
down through here we were always scared
of them you know so growing up it was
pretty it was wild they were Infamous
right yeah yeah they'd come in there and
get light bread and blone from our
grandpa I mean and they wouldn't knock
or nothing I mean they just walk on in
like like they own the house and just
grab a loaf of bread and a pack of Boney
and the door they they'd go with that
sounds like Ray yeah yeah it'd be Ray
and pretty
there's something I mean but um it we
scared to death of them at the time but
it just I don't know it's just something
crazy I mean cuz you look back on it and
they're normal people I
mean and um they wouldn't hurt a flea no
no they're just like
kids it's something
that then um there's times I've seen
them upset oh yeah for sure I've seen
them upset at times people come down
here firecrackers throwing at them and
um that's how that's right before you
came I mean they was so nervous and
stuff cuz I mean they had buckets of
rocks sitting here beside the road
thinking this people going to hurt them
and going to throw rocks at people's
vehicles and
um it it was sad I mean you got College
people coming down here trying to trying
to scare them and stuff it's I mean it
was crazy we grew up watching all this
and it was crazy it was a crazy life
what was it like growing up here not a
lot not a lot of opportunity for not a
lot of opportunities at all and nothing
hardly I mean the coal mines come
through and then right after the coal
mines come through the oxycotton come
through so and that's when we uh all the
coal miners got addicted to the pills
and the next thing you know the town
really went to
hell and cuz everybody knows each other
I mean we're so close so everybody was
on
oxycotton next thing I know I was
breaking in Coal Mines stealing copper
to support my habit I I went to jail
twice over it I mean cuz I was going
inside the co mes get getting the copper
to sell support my habit I had my truck
stolen um I've been sprayed in the face
with a fire
extinguisher dude try to run me over my
own
truck for for stealing things yeah
stealing Min bits mhm just I mean
everybody's so strung out it it's it's
sad what what percentage of your friends
are are not involved in
drugs probably 30 yeah maybe
30% it's hard it's it's so rough it's
sad it's so
rough why is it that so many people here
into drugs I don't know I mean is there
nothing to do on weekends there's
nothing to do here period nothing the
young people or the older people this
place is dead I mean it's it's like it's
dying out quick
and there's no money to fund anything
nothing I mean so there's nothing to do
it's hard to make a dollar around here
especially now that it's gotten worse
now with the co Min is closing down I
mean there there's no jobs really to be
no money to be made here period
really and then you get unhooked on dope
then you go go robing stealing I mean
it's they try to support you hav it and
it just you end up in jail or prison you
guys both had trouble with prison yeah
I've done about 20 years in 20 years for
what arm robbery got hooked on oxycotton
went and robbed the
pharmacy done seven years got out went
Rob the same Pharmacy again second time
second time went back and done five more
years and then got out and went back
again for four more years over drugs
it's all drug related so you rob the
same pharmac I robbed same Pharmacy
twice got caught both times I don't know
why I was thinking I get away with the
second
time first time I got away with all the
pills and everything inside so I thought
I'd do it second time second time it
didn't end so
well they cornered me in right there at
the store have you guys ever thought
about leaving this part of the country
yeah going have you have you ever
traveled have you been anywhere else C
States yeah Virginia North Carolina
Georgia yeah but those aren't
drastically different from here it's not
much different from here may maybe a
little more opportunity but not not like
going to you you've been to Atlanta or
Miami or Chicago or no nothing like
that I've been to California a couple
times I had a chance to stay out there
and I just the dope had me so strung out
I mean I just couldn't I couldn't put
the dope down on they got they got dope
in California trust me yeah I've been
trying to get him to go to California
for years now and he won't
go it's just just it's sad I mean when
it gets a hold of you I mean now I'm
getting older realizing time's passing
by quick and it's just I got kids and
stuff and it's just it's getting it's
time to move on and get out of sticks
yeah how old are you guys I'm I'm 39 I'm
39 42 39 42 and you have kids no I don't
I got three you have three kids yeah are
you still on their lives oh yeah yeah I
got a 16-year-old um about a 4-year-old
and a
3-year-old it's it's rough I mean it is
the thing to to consider like if I was a
parent and I had kids here I would see
20 20 years in the future and see that
there's not going to be anything for
them anybody nothing here from nobody
anymore if I had a family I'd definitely
want to pack up I'd pack up and go to
Chicago or Atlanta or New York somewhere
where there's opportunities for kids
yeah cuz it's getting worse here day by
day 16y old needs a car and I I can't
AFF a car for I mean that's how that is
when I first started coming here there
was coal mining for everybody yeah and
that was rough because that was the only
option but at least it was an option
yeah now you don't G Coes don't shut
down I mean it's dead I mean it's just a
dead dead place is there anybody that's
thriving and killing
it I don't know of any yeah I mean
everybody
knows disabled I mean from the co mes or
and then there's you allow a crime here
too
a lot of crime a lot yeah like what kind
of crime breaking breaking in houses lot
of petty thefts
robberies just want they can get their
hands on more or less
yeah it's sad I mean it's it's real sad
you see drugs has took over everything
now and you watch people that you growed
up around dying overdosing I mean it's
every day you lost a lot of friends yeah
about about 60 or 70% of our friends
done overdose died died yeah 60 70% of
your friends are dead yeah they and g
wow I mean it's sad I mean it you look
back up and you start counting so many
people that done overdosed and passed
away I mean it it breaks your
heart heroin and mats really took over
everything around here now that that's
when that's when they started dropping
over when the H meth
come it was overdose overdose I
mean it was it's crazy I mean it's and
people wonder why you get on the drugs
well once you're on the drugs you don't
feel like this you don't realize all
this is going on around you when you're
high on that you know you're on top of
the world yeah you're out on a beach
somewhere in California you know the
herin makes makes you forget about how
forget about all this how Bleak this is
yeah so when you sober up you're like
[__] that I'm going go back and get get
some more dope yeah next thing you know
you're strung out addict you know you
done did half your life in prison
and you're a piece of [__] in some
people's eyes then and you do do some
dope and you it all goes life everyday
struggle I mean it's just it makes
everything better seems
like I mean it's sad it really is it's
heartbreaking what was your childhood
like childhood was normal really yeah
you had good parents yeah had really
good parents yeah our parents was good I
mean we I I hunt and fished a lot I mean
we kept wheer
but um everyday normal kid stuff around
here but then once you turn into you
know get teenage years you start
experiment with drugs and it's all in
schools around here I mean and your
friends it starts out your friends on it
then well I want to try to see see how
how I can feel on it then that's when
it's really bad cuz once you get out of
school it's you're on the streets trying
to get dope and it's it's hard problem
is around here your shelter from
everything you know this is Backwoods
living right here you know we don't
really know what's going on with the
rest of the world when you're secluded
down here in O uh have no idea what's
going on it's
a and it's just you know everybody you
know when the cops coming I mean cuz you
get you get a phone call cops is on the
way down be just watch your butt I mean
it's it's crazy a you know when they're
coming you know when they're leaving
everybody knows everybody everybody
knows every yeah nothing's a
secret it's it's it's it's crazy I mean
it's once you're branded a drug
addict once you're considered a drug
addict nobody wants to fool with you you
know you're a piece of [__] in their
eyes until they need help from you you
know then they yeah then they want to
butter you up
and till they get done with they they
use you then everybody has an addiction
for something you know everybody depends
on something to get them through yeah
nobody's perfect I mean it just but down
in in the sticks it's it's rougher I
mean it dope's harder to get I mean
everything's so much harder to get hard
to get pay for food I mean I I struggle
a lot I mean I do where I got a family
and I have it it's it's heartbreaking I
mean I I don't know I just pry good Lord
I can stop it one day and did you regret
not leaving this area yeah yeah I do I
mean I regret it a lot you could have
easily just to packed up yeah I had
chance after chance steal can any day
you know right I just need to realize
for my family and and and and pack up
and go but it's it's hard to leave it's
hard to leave place that you grow up at
I mean that yeah the longer you stay
here the last you the last chances you
are to succeed anywhere else you go mhm
but you're getting older and older and
it a it ain't getting any better out
there I've been blowned up by a gas
grill I
mean crazy stuff I mean I've been shot
with a pellet gun in the neck about
about
DED I blow up all high on MTH yeah all
high on MTH MTH yep that's the worstest
thing I mean that I'm thinking people's
in the woods that watching you and I
mean it's
think drones is following you I mean
it's it's crazy and the and the drugs
are coming from where I we don't know
they just they're here they're here
they're here it's easy to find too we
was doing it I mean they're easy to find
just expensive to get so you that's
brings the crime rate up then you got to
steal to get get stuff and that's that's
when you end up in jail
yeah you go to jail and you learn a
whole new hustle and come back out and
same thing it's a slower Pace here than
it is in the big world I guess big city
yeah yeah it's cuz I don't know why it's
just it's slower Pace here
mhm you can still get in trouble you'll
still find trouble though everywhere as
you look yes sir once the cops knows you
I mean they're they stay on you I mean
it's like day and night I mean you get
out and there they are bam right they're
right on
you or let you down in the holler
where you can get a phone call telling
them they're coming down in the holler
but it's a beautiful area it's very
beautiful yeah it's it's peaceful I mean
it's it's peace and
quiet what's your favorite memory as a
kid growing up
here probably come down see see our
grandpa I mean
just our dad used to let us drive a car
when we was little on the dirt roads and
it was fun I mean we we sat on his lap
and then and
steer the car I mean it it was good
times and that's where all these drugs
come you know I mean it it was a normal
life seemed like you have memories other
than Ray walking in the house for bread
Ray and Freddy yeah I've got a few
memories of coming down by here and
seeing Ray and him standing
out what uh Ray be standing out with his
pants down around his ankles W yeah I've
told that story before many times yeah
ra raised pants around his ankles
Ray wants your hat you had to give him
your hat something flashy on your arm or
something he he had he wanted it I mean
he loved hats he loved watches I mean he
shoes he he loves shoes I probably give
him 25 hats at least a dozen watches
yeah ra ra fun my dad stopped down here
he just bought us a goat cart I I'll
never forget he stopped here talk talked
to one of them and Freddy and Ray come
up to the truck they was pointing at the
goat cart and I and I had a hat on and
then they come up to the truck and we
had a bag of hamburgers for McDonald's
but we gave him the hamburgers and I I
thought they was want my my new goat
cart I I scared to death and you they
pointing at my hat I gave him my hat I
gave him the cheeseburgers I get but I
didn't want to get him my goat card up I
was scared to
death I kept telling my dad I'm ready
Dad I'm ready and and it was it was
I mean but they're just big kids what
they was yeah that's exactly what they
are has this area how has it changed in
the last 20 years cuz you used like you
have Walmart now at least yeah 20 years
ago you didn't have Walmart no you had
nothing nothing that you know the stores
Walmart and Lowe's is about two biggest
things they brought in that's the only
thing they really brought in honestly I
mean
um
I'll let it go
by it's a loud one yeah Walmart and lows
Walmart lows that changed a lot of
things uh brought a lot of job
opportunity here and then uh but it
seems like all the people leaving nobody
wants to stay around you know
everything's dying out now mhm so all
the people's gone every day you see less
and less people seem like I mean you
don't know if they're gone out of state
you don't know if they're dead I mean
you you just don't know anymore
emotionally what does it do to you you
get depressed it's depressed you stay
depressed a lot around here I mean it's
it's sad cuz I mean you stay depressed
more than you do happy I mean it's if
you ain't on drugs when you get here you
will be when you leave yeah yeah you
stay long enough yeah that's how that's
how how sad it is around here I mean I I
hate to see kids grow up here anymore
honestly cuz they there's nothing to do
I mean just watch watch other people do
dope I mean that that's going to make
anyone to do it
right all right Wayne and Scotty thank
you so much for sharing your stories
thank you I wish you guys lots of luck
all right thank you all right man thank
you